اعلنت هيئه المحامله التونسيه لتنظيم ما
سمته يوم غضب وطنين الخميس المقبل رفض
لقانون الماليه الجديد واذ قال كاهل
التونسيين بالاعباء الضريبيه المفرطه بحسب
تعبيرها وهدد الاتحاد التونسي للشغل بانه
لن يقف مكتوف الايدي تجاه الازمه في
البلاد بينما اعلن الرئيس قيس سعيد تمديد
حاله الطوارئ واتهم المعارضه
ورفع الاسعار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات الثلاثه ما دلاله التوالد دعوات
النقابيه للاحتجاج ضد سياسات الرئيس وما
فرص استخدامه الطوارئ لعرقله التحركات
العمليه استنادا الى صلاحيات التي تشمل
منع الاضرابات بدون اذن القضاء وما مغزى
اتهام سعيد المعارضه بافتعال الازمات
وتحميلها المسؤوليه عن غلاء الاسعار في
هذا التوقيت وما خيارات المعارضه للتعامل
معه في المرحله المقبله وكيف ستنعكس
الازمه السياسيه المتساعده في تونس ونظر
الاحتقان الاجتماعيه المحتمل على
الميزانيه ومفاوضات صندوق النقد الدولي
وما تاثيرها على الوضع المعيشي التونسيين
[موسيقى]
فيما بدا تحديا اجتماعيا جديده للرئيس
التونسيه اعلنت هيئه المحاميه تنظيم ما
سمعته يوم غضب وطني يوم الخميس المقبل رفض
لقانون الماليه الجديد الذي ينتظر ان يرفع
الضرائب على المحامين وقطاعات الاخرى
بمقدار 50% ايات المحاميه قررت احتجاجها
ايضا بمسمته التداعيات الخطيره على الشعب
واذ قال كاهله بالاعباء الضريبيه المفرطه
التي تحد من القدره الشرائيه للمواطنين
وفي خطبه ابعد في هذه في هذا الاتجاه
لمقاومه السياسات قيس سعيد كشفت النقابه
عن انها فوضت عميد المحامين للتنسيق مع
المنظمات ومكونات المجتمع المدني بهدف
اطلاقه مبادرته وطنيه لانقاذ البلاد وداعه
الرئيس الى التعامل بايجابيه مع ما تنصفه
عليه هذه المبادره
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل ايضا وعلى لسان
المتحدث باسمه سامي الطاهر وصل تهديده
بمواجهه السياسات الرئيس قيس سعيد اكد انه
لن يبقى مكتوف الايدي تجاه الازمه
الاجتماعيه في تونس سامي الطاهر اضاف ان
الاتحاد سيبدا تحركات الاحتجاجيه سيحدد
موعدها في اجتماعه هيئته الاداريه الشهر
المقبل واوضح ان الاتحاد يعتزم واطلاقا
مبادره مع منظمه المجتمع المدني لكن هذه
المبادره لا تزال في مرحله المشاوره واكد
المتحدث باسم اتحاد الشغل ان الاتحاد لا
ينوي تجاوز رئيس الجمهوريه وسيعرض عليهم
مبادراته رغم استبعاده قبول الرئيس
بالمبادره والدخول في حوار مع المنظمات
المدنيه
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد وخلال اجتماع مع
رئيسه الحكومه ووزير العدل والداخليه قال
ان التحدي الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه من اهم
التحديات التي يواجهها التونسيون لكن سعيد
لماح الى تحميل المعارضه مسؤوليه ما اله
اليه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في البلاد حين
قال ان افتعال الازمات وفقدان بعض المواد
الاساسيه وغلاء الاسعار والمحاولات التي
باتت معلومه للجميع لا يمكن ان تستمر
بحسبره
الازمات القائمه قال سعيد ان غيابك قضاء
عادل يجعله من المستحيل تحقيقه اي هدف من
اهداف الشعب التونسي وانه يجب تطبيق
القانون على الجميع على قدم المساوا وفق
قوله
قيس سعيد كان قد مدد حاله الطوارئ بالبلاد
لشهر اضافي حتى ال 30 من يناير المقبل
والقى برسوم الرئاسيين صدر في جريده
الرسميه تمديد حاله الطوارئ يتم بشكل دوري
منذ اعاده العمل بها كثره تفجير الذي
استهدف حافله للامن الرئاسي وسط العاصمه
في نوفمبر عام 2015
وتخول حاله الطوارئ للسرطان صلاحيات
صلاحياتنا استثنائيه واسعه كحضر تجول
الافراد والمركبات ومنع الاضرابات
العماليه بدون اذن مسبق من القضاء
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس جوهر
بالمبارك القياديه في جبهه الخلاصه
الوطنيه ومن سوسه شرقي تونس قيصر الصياح
المحامي والباحث في القانون وابدا بك سيد
قيصر كيف ينبغي للرئيس ان يقرا هذه
الاعلانات من نقابه المحامين التي اعقبت
اعلانات ممثله من الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
على لسان اليمين الى العام قبل ايام حينما
قالت سنحتل الشوارع وعلى لسان النائب نائب
الامين العام حينما حدث اليوم سن الطاهر
عن انه لن يقف مكتوب العيد
هل سمعت السؤال الاستاذ
قيصر
سنعود الى السيد قيصر حينما نتمكن من ذلك
لكن اثر نفس السؤال الاستاذ جوهر بن مبارك
هذا هذه هل نحن امام حركه اجتماعيه غير
مسبوقه حركه احتجاجات عماليه غير مسبوقه
في هذا التوقيت ضد قيس سعيد
نعم هو نسق تصاعدي اعتقد ان ال
الازمه تشتد احتيادا وعزله قيس سعيد تزداد
يوما بعد يوم الان بعد مضيئه اكثر من سنه
و سبعه اشهر على انقلاب قيس سعيد صارت
تونس تعيش في ظله ازمه مركبه ومعقده جدا
ذات ابعاد مختلفه تشمل كامل مجالات الحياه
التونسيه الحياه السياسيه الحياه
الاقتصاديه الحياه الاجتماعيه الحياه
النقديه المجتمع المدني هناك الان تبلور
لموقف وطني جامع تقريبا باشماع كل النخبه
والتحقت به ايضا جحاف المؤا- الاف مؤلفه
من ابناء تونس وبناتها من ابناء الشعب
الذين اصبحوا
كود البلاد الى هلاكها يعني التطور هو نعم
يعني يبدو ان يعني الذي يقرا في لغه
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل وايضا نقابه
المحامين يشعر انه هنالك فارقا بين ما
يدعون اليه وما تدعو اليه جبهه الخلاص
يعني جبهه الخلاص تريد همم
ان يستقيل ان يتنحر رئيس هو حرك سياسي لكن
حرص شغل ونقابه المحامين على ان يكون
حراقهما حراكا اجتماعيه اقتصاديه خاصه فقط
بقانون الميزانيه
القانون الماليه
ولكن في نفس الوقت اتحاد الشغل يتحدث عن
الوضع السياسي ويتحدث عن مبادره سياسيه
ساعود الى هذه النقطه المبادره السياسيه
للمجتمع المدني والاتحاد الشغل ولكن الاهم
من كل هذا هو ان الاصوات تتعالى من كل حب
وصوب الان ضد قيس سعيد وضد السياسات قيسي
سعيد وضد خيارات قيس سعيد هناك اصوات
متجذره في مقاومتها للانقلاب منذ 25
جويليه هذه الاصوات الان همم تتجذر اكثر
فاكثر وتطالب برحيل قيس سعيد وباقاله وعزل
او استقاله قيس سعيد وتحديد موعد
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المبكره بمعنى انها
وصلت الى قناعه وعلى راسها جامعه الخلاصه
الوطنيه
بعد مقاطعه التونسيون والتونسي والتونسيات
للانتخابات الاخيره ورقم ثمانيه فاصل
ثمانيه المهزله الذي سجله الانقلاب في
انتخاباته الاخيره
همم نزعت عنه كل الشرعيه والمشروعيه وصارت
هناك ازمه شرعيه حقيقيه الان في تونس
عميقه تتطلب تجديد الشرعيه تجديد العهده
تجديد همم الثقه اعتقد ان تونس اليوم في
مفترق طرق وان من حق التونسيين ان يحسموا
في هذه الخيارات بين مسار قيس سعيد الذي
نعتبره مسارا عبثيا اعتباطيا وبين مسار
همم استئناف العمليه الديمقراطيه يجب ان
نسمح للتونسيين الان بان يحسنوا هذا
الصراع عبر صناديق اقتراع النزيهات شريف
عليها هيئه انتخابيه نزيهه ومحايده وهكذا
يمكن ان نستانف عمليه البناء الديمقراطيه
وذهاب ورحيل قيس سعيد في نفس الوقت
شرقيه تونس قيصر السياحه المحامي والباحث
في القانون همم كيف تنظر انت الى الفارق
بين احتجاج جامعه الخلاص والاحزاب
السياسيه المعار للرئيس قيس سعيد والتي
تسمي اجراءاتهم انقلابا وبين ما هددت به
نقابه المحامين وهدد به اتحاد التونسي
للشغل
شكرا مساء الخير مساء الخير
اولا لاراده الشعبيه اقوى بكثير من اراده
المعارضه ومن رغبه المعارضه ومن نوايا
المعارضه ولو ان المعارضه جزء لا يتجزا من
الديمقراطيه ومن هيكله الدوله ومن اساسها
السلطه وفي تسير شؤون المرفق العام
بالبلاد التونسيه ثانيا المعارضه ليست صوت
الوحيد في تونس لتقوله كلماتها قبل الشعب
والشعب قال كلماته انتخابات الرئاسيه وفي
استفتاء عام حر مباشره
قال فيه كلمته واصبح الان امرا واقع عن
طريق ماتيا وليس فيولوجيا كما تريد
المعارضه في تفسيراتها لعلم اللاهوت
السياسي ثالثا الموضوع الذي يتعلق الان
وهو موضوع حاسم
بالمبادره التي
سيقوم بها الاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل مع
الهيئه الوطنيه للمحاميه مع مناظمه
التونسيه الدفاع الحقوق الانسان في مبادره
مستقله ومختلفه تاما تماما الاختلاف عن
التوجه الذي ما هو المعارضه او تتخيلوا
كان انتقلت من مرحله الهيمنه سلطه والحكم
الى مرحله البحث عن صفحه الان وقد قضي
الامر وكان امرا مقضيا لانه الان الرئيس
يعني ما الذي تتوقعه من المبادره وايضا
كيف تنظر الى الاحتجاجات التي يهدد بها
الاتحاد الشغل وهدد بها نقابه المحامين
اتحاد الشغل على الرساله مين العام قال
سنحتل الشوارع
نعم في عنصر
يجيبك عن هذه النقطه بالذات
يعني ارجو ان تساعدنا التكنولوجيا
والانترنت في تونس على ان توشيبا لكن واضح
انه لا يوجد هذه المساعده الان من
التكنولوجيا ربما نعود اليك مره ثانيه
وهنا اريد ان اسال الاستاذ جواهر وهو يقول
انه وكما قلت في البدايه يا استاذ جوهر ان
ما يطرح اتحاد الشغل وما تطرحه نقابه
المحامين ليست له اي صبغه سياسيه وما
يتحدثان عن مشكل اقتصادي اجتماعي وليس عن
المشكله السياسي يعني لم يسموا مثلا
الرئيس بالمنقلب او ما شابه ذلك وانهم لن
يتجاوز الرئيس وسيعرضون عليه مبادرتهم
هنالك فارق بين ما يطرح واتحاد الشغل
ونقابه المحامين وبين ما تطرحونه
نعم ولكن شيئين يجب التمييز بينهما
التحركات الاحتجاجيه التي يجمع اتحاد
الشغل والنقابات الاخرى اييي القيام بها
حتى النقابات الامنيه هي الان محتجه
ومعتصمه وتقوم باحتجاجات في علاقه
بالقضايا الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه ولكن
هناك ايضا مسار اخر يتحدث عن الاتحاد وهو
مسار سياسي مسار المبادره السياسيه لحل
حاله الازمه السياسيه كما كما يراها نحن
في كل الحالات قلنا موقفنا بكل وضوح لان
المبادره باتجاه قيس سعيد انتهى وقتها
وفاه وقتها من زمان وانا قيس سعيد ساره هو
سبب المشكله واحد عناصر الاساسيه للمشكله
ولم يقوله بكل حال من الاحوال جزء من
الاحل انا استغرب الى حد الان كيف يمكن ان
يطمع اتحاد الشغل في ان يستمع اليه قيس
سعيد بعد ان رفض الاستماع لكل الاطراف بما
فيها لحد مرات ومرات المره والمره قبل
الانقلاب وبعد همم اعتقد ان قيس سعيد همم
ماض في طريقه الهلامي ماضي همم المزيد
تقزيم الوضع في البلاد ولكن نحن لا نعتبر
ان سنتعاطى مع كل المبادرات الوطنيه
تعاطيا ايجابيا الا تلك التي تنوي انقاذ
الانقلاب
ان مبادره اتحاد الشغل هي لانقاذ الانقلاب
نحن ننتظر هذه المبادره ننتظر مضمونها
ننتظر ماذا تقترح ثم لمن توجه انا اعتقد
ان المبادرات الان يجب ان توجهها الى
الشعب التونسي وليس الى قيس سعيد ان توجه
الى المجتمع السياسي والمدني ولا توجه الى
قيس سعيد اولا ثانيا ان يكون مضمونها سقفه
الادنى هو رحيل القيس سعيد
وعزل القيسي سعيد والمرور الى مرحله جديده
ان كان هذا الامر دون هذا السقف ودون هذا
الهدف اعتقد اننا همم انها مرفوضه ستكون
مرفوضه همم
سنعود الى هذه النقطه لكن اخشى ان نفقد
الاتصال مره اخرى بضيفنا من سوسه السيد
قيصر السياح وكنت اسالك عن توقعك للمبادره
كنت تشرع في شرح
المبادره والفرق بين احتجاج
جبهه الخلاص وبين الاحتجاجات المزمعه من
نقابه المحامين ومن اتحاد الشغل تفضل
نعم نعم شكرا شكرا
جيد جدا باعتبار انه سؤال مفصلي بمفترق
طرق سياسي الان تمر به البلاد اولا بغادر
التي اطلقها الاتحاد العام التونسي
تماما من حيث شكله من حيث
واعطيات
للاسف انقطع مره اخرى الاتصال من سوسه
بالقيصر السياحه عود مره الى مره اخرى
اليك لنكمل الاستاذ جوهر ابن مبارك اذا
المبادره اذا لم يكن سقفها رحيل قيس سعيد
جابت الخريطه سترفضها مغادره اتحاد الشغل
منذ انقلاب 25 جويليه قلنا بان الشرعيه
الدستوريه سقطت على قيس سعيد ولم يعد
نعترف به رئيسا
للجمهوريه رئيسا شرعيا للجمهوريه ثم ااه
سقطت المشروعيه الشعبيه
بحكم ارقام صناديق الاقتراع التي وضعها
بنفسه بشروط الذي وضعها هو وبالقانون الذي
وضعه هو وباشراف التي نصبها بنفسه همم
كانت نسبه المشاركه همم
نسبه المشاركه في الجوله الاولى هذه
الانتخابات لا ننسى ان لها جوله ثانيه وان
هذه النسب يمكن ان تتعدل في الجوله
الثانيه
لا هو المفروض انا في الجولات الجوله
الثانيه ان يسبب تزيد انخفاضا لان عدد
الدوائر التي سيكون فيها انتخابات هو اقل
من الدوره الاولى وعدد المترشحين اقل يعني
ان الديناميكا الانتخابيه في الدوره
الثانيه دائما تكون اقل من الدوره الاولى
ولكن ليس هذا
المهم المهم هو اننا همم وصلنا الان الى
الدرك الاسفل من المشروعيه الشعبيه برقم
همم
يعني لماذا ينظر هذا الشغل
يلعب في هذه الانتخابات رئيس الجمهوريه
يريد ان يلعب في هذه الانتخابات شوطا
ثانيا في حين انه خسر المباراه بالغياب من
الشوط الاول يعني لم يلعب الشوط الاول هو
خسر المباراه اصلا
وانتهى الامر هو يريد ان يتدارك ويلتحق
الرصاصه التي خرجت همم لكن انتهى الامر
مثلا انتهت همم اعتقد ان اتحاد الشغل عليه
ان ياخذ بعين الاعتبار في كل المبادرات
السياسيه وضع المشروعيه الان في تونس
والوضع الشرعي هل ان الرئيس
سعيد لا يزال رئيسا شرعيا يمكن التعاطي
معه او ان البلاد تحتاج الى اعاده بناء
الشرعيه والمشروعيه همم الشعبيه الشرعيه
الدستوريه والمشروعيه الشعبيه هذه هي هذا
السؤال وهذا هو اصل الازمه همم الازمه
اصلها السياسيه عاد الينا عبر الهاتف هذه
المره من سوسه الاستاذ قيصر السياحه
الازمه اصلها
واي مبادره سواء جاءت من اتحاد الشغل او
من نقابه المحامين او من اي جهه لا تخاطب
المشكل السياسي همم فهي محكوم عليها
بالفشل حتى شروط صندوق النقد الدولي تتحدث
عن مناخ جاذب للاستثمار والمناخ الجذب
للاستثمار هو الاستقرار السياسي الرئيس
بدل ذلك يقفز الى الامام ويتهم المعارضه
بانها المسؤوله عن غيابه عن غلاء الاسعار
كيف يمكن ان نفهم ذلك كيف يمكن اتهام
المعارضه
بالمسؤوليه عن غلاء الاسعار
المعارضه اولا هي من اوجدت فكره المشروعيه
والشرعيه وانتصبت حكما قضاه الرئيس ولي
العزل الرئيس والمعارضه التي تتحدث الان
وانا اخالف ضيفه في كل ما قاله اي جزء من
المعارضه ولي كل المعارضه هناك سته احزاب
يا سيدي من الاحزاب الكبرى حركه الشعب
والتيار الشعبي وتونس الى الامام
مع الرئيس السيسي
للشغل في شخص نبيل العام منذ يوم 24 ساعه
فقط
انه لا رجوع الى الوراء ولا رجوع الى يوم
24 يونيو
اذا كنت تتحدث عن الوراء ما قبل 25 جويليه
فحتى المعارضه تقول لك لا نريد العوده الى
ما قبل 25 جويليه لكن اي وراء هناك
كثير من الوراء حدث بعد ذلك الوراء الذي
حدث بعد 25 يناير 25 يوليو التحدث تونسي
للشغل يقول لابد ان نرجع لابد ان نرجع
يطالب الرئيس بالمراجعه ويقول ان هذا هو
العقل الراجحي الذي يفعل ذلك
شغل يطالب فقط باصلاح وتعديل الاوتار في
جزئيات معاينه تتعلق بانحراف المسار في
بعض الجزئيات كما يراه هو لكنه التي كان
صريحا في موضوع ما قبل 25 يوم قال لي
رجوعه الى ما قبل 25 يوليو اضيفوا هناك
شيئا مهما لم يتطرق اليه ضيفه الهيئه
الوطنيه المحاميين لشخص عميد
حقوقيه مناظله وعلاقه في تاريخ النضال
الدوسي اصدرت بيان الرسميه منذ الامر
وطرحت فيه كل الحلال انا وليه الرجوع الى
ما قبل 25 يوم انا الهيئه الوطنيه
في البلاد
على مناظمه الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان لخلق
جو مناخ اجتماعي جديد على الاقل يعدل
الاوتار سواء كانت تعلق الامر بقانون
الماليه لسنه 23 او ثم يتعلق بالحقوق
الاجتماعيه التي تتعرض الى بعض الاهتزازات
والعينات
والتي ادت الى ضعف في المقبره الشرائيه
المواطنه والدفاع عن حقوق الماديه
والمعارضه الان ليست
غلط وعين قاضي ذكر رئيس الرئيس يعزيل
الشعب ويعينه الشعب وانتخابه بطريقه
الشرعيه
عليه ثلاثه ملايين من البشر اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا من سوسه
قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون
واشكر ضيفنا من تونس جوهر بن المبارك
القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
نصل بذلك الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]